you get us a call from a school
principal or whatever and say hey Bart
Tycho was you know get in a fight and uh
put this bully in a in an arm bar a real
rear naked choke hold what are your
first thoughts and feelings I'm taking
them out for ice cream
[Music]
these are for the Jiu Jitsu boys out
here
wipe out all the fans out there can I be
in it
13 year old Brazilian Brazilian
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu Prodigy eliminates a
school bully with her skills yo let's go
ahead and watch this little video 13 13
year old can't mess with these kids no
more man this article was submitted by
one of our amazing patrons uh Lima burn
78 so thank you so much Lima burn 7A for
giving us this amazing article hey hey
Nick after you watch this can you tell
me if you think she could beat my ass
because I'm pretty good at Jiu Jitsu
I'll probably say yeah okay can you guys
Sam I see can you guys yep
but you're the one that taught me so
that means she can be you yeah she could
probably kick my ass too
oh [__] I know the bully was a guy nope
she's a little ass girl that's honored
it's like a spider monkey [__] with a
tourist it looks like the teacher is
trying to stop them but at the same time
doesn't know how it is no he doesn't
know what to do dude he she putting her
to sleep
oh where the rough at yo tap out dude
tap out
now she gets she gets her in the arm bar
afterwards
hey that's not in America oh she rolls
an armor
she's gonna break it that's what she
said oh she's kicking her in the face
bro can you go take your seats please
yo they're speaking are you sure it's
Brazil they're speaking English it's
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
are you sure it's Brazil
he looks so sad dude don't be
disappointed Joe it's okay I heard a
girl in Brazil
don't be mad at me dude here have a
cookie man I already ate too much what
are you trying to do [__] make me
diabetic geez Anthony
so do you think a [__] her up
I think yeah maybe yeah maybe all right
50 50 chance oh really that's a pretty
high chance that's good dude I'm Gonna
Keep training at Lionheart so I can be a
hundred percent [__] her up yeah dude so
this 13 year old girl her name is
Apollonia nuncio I believe uh she grew
tired of being bullied at the school
that and she's been dealing with this
same bully girl for weeks she looked
like a stereotypical bully girl too
because she's fat yeah she looked like
both she looked like bulk from Power
Rangers dude this girl this girl for
weeks is probably like I don't want to
have to [__] you up I don't have to [__]
you up yeah I don't have to [__] you up
in and then she kind of did [__] her ass
up
that's exactly the story is basically
that simple like she was Fed Up wanted
to do something about it you know what I
mean
um and she she was not one to brag or
boast about her martial arts training or
anything like that either
um she was kind of a quiet girl uh and
it was just kind of one of those moments
where after weeks of disrespect and
stuff like that and rumors of course
because School uh it just built up to a
breaking point so she's going against as
you can see in the video that went super
viral on Twitter as well she's going
against this much larger girl almost
doubled her size but regardless
disadvantaged I say triple or like
quadruple
tuck on that girl stop being a bully
because random people on the internet
are gonna pick on you too so she's you
know for anybody who wasn't able to see
the video clearly uh she gets onto her
back puts her you know what I mean like
really just gets into a rear naked
chocolate is that what it's called Uh
and then they both go down go down to
the ground and then she transitions into
a full extended arm bar where he's gonna
break my arm bully girl yeah you're
gonna break it she's gonna break it then
she got kicked in the
but those kicks they were clean so I
didn't feel as bad yeah because she
didn't have dog [__] on them you know
if only she stepped in dog [__] before
so like uh Bart obviously you're putting
like taika through Jujitsu right now
like if you get us a call from a school
principal or whatever and say hey Bart
tiger was you know get in a fight and uh
put this bully in a in an arm bar a real
rear naked choke hold what are your
first thoughts and feelings he puts a
bully in one yeah I'm taking him out for
ice cream
let's get into Sunday you can get both
flavors of what you want
what if after that he starts [__] so he
could take down bullies so he could
always get ice cream
I remember I I fought back against the
bullying one time oh yeah yeah what was
happening set the stage okay so it was
during it was during lunch and I was
doing this girl's homework right and uh
it's yeah I know I was down bad before I
don't think I was you know you're just
being nice right finally game flirting
yeah early game flirting
um
and you know while I was doing her
homework this this this this guy across
the table he was like chucking food at
me right what kind of food was it it was
like it was like it was like carrots and
peas oh the bad stuff yeah and like like
look I could I could I could take the
shots for a little bit right like so
but then he he dipped like this this
carrot in like and like ketchup oh no
and then and then it hit not even four
inch what a dweeb ketchup who did right
like like Ranch I could probably
yeah it's a good combo
but but then it hit my forehead Landing
her on her homework oh no right look you
could get at me all you want yeah but
once you get on my lady yeah like nah
that's it you got to do something the
lady that hasn't kissed me yet but I'm
doing her homework I'm gonna get that
kiss though yeah now I'm really not
gonna get the kiss because my future
wife's homework
she got a boyfriend even though she got
what she might kiss me later you never
know even if the bullies her boy [__]
yeah
if I if I wait long enough yeah
um and so so then I got I got so fed up
I I crumble her homework I I
collateral damage bro that's so
unnecessary oh
you ruin
Ed for her because she should do her own
homework yeah she's only cheating
herself right yeah cheating herself
uh no for the right guy I offered I
think she does her do her homework yeah
yeah my bad my bad okay the flow of this
story is getting cut a lot let's just go
back to him so so I walk across the
table and and I just slam his head oh
[__] like like three times hell yeah you
know what I don't think that's fighting
back that sounds like assault
damn that's [__] kind of gangster and
then what happened and and then I and I
and I saw I saw he was bleeding and his
glasses broke he got glasses yo you got
a Nerf bullying you wait which one's the
bully you or him yeah wait did you have
glasses
you can't beat up a guy with glasses on
and you don't got glasses yeah no no he
was uh built different but I
it's
I what happened oh yeah I went to after
that I just I ran out of the cafeteria
and I just sat in the Halls yeah and
just kind of like reflected like like
what the [__] just he did he did have it
coming but him wearing glasses doesn't
help your case so if you were to tell on
you or something no he did no I I got
detention oh that's it he told on you
yeah what a [__] man you beat up a nerd
dude he's just like walking around he's
got like blood coming down his face with
broken glasses somebody's like what
happened oh these are [__] though
yeah they are you keep your mouth shut
though
did you like know him or did was he just
some random he just sat in in the same
table as us oh okay yeah but he thought
he was being funny yeah yeah yeah it was
just it was a fun thing to do
interesting yeah the craziest part
though is like like for for the longest
time I was like withholding these shots
huh I just snapped bro I just I think
you had to though you had to so what
happened to you guys is Rapport after
that did you ever have to run into him
and stuff like was he nicer to you was
he no we kind of just avoided each other
for the rest of this you should have you
should
his glasses all [__] up and [__] yeah
yeah you already switched to contacts
after that huh
you probably need to yeah yeah in case
you get rocked again all you've got was
detention that's pretty good that's
pretty sweet that would be like a
suspension or like out usually yeah
fight yeah usually a fight would be a
suspension maybe New York kids are built
differently oh yeah New York that that
happens oh okay that's different there's
a soft soft Cali schools yeah
they probably go to jail dude cops five
seconds you go to real jail I do like
the idea of uh fighting back well again
just no the joy of this particular video
because when it specifically paints a
picture of like a bully that's like two
or three times your size and especially
with girls too because then when you're
looking at this you you're not putting
the same type of like ink stores like
teenage boys who are just getting in
like fights for no [__] reason yeah
you know what I'm saying and you see
stuff like this and you're like at least
for me I'm like oh [__] like when I was
a small kid yeah and I was in [__] like
taekwondo
I maybe had the confidence but it was
Taekwondo so I'm still gonna get my ass
kicked you don't know that you might
have kicked the dude in the face
very true if you bounced enough yeah if
you were yeah you're not helping the
picture nah bro Taekwondo don't don't
[__] talk [__] about it Taekwondo
over but when I see stuff like this and
you can literally see a way smaller kid
handle a bully yeah like that [__] is
like okay cool like like it makes me
want to be like yeah I'd rather one of
my favorite things about Jiu Jitsu is
that uh you can actually
subdue someone without hurting them yeah
whereas like any other the Striking arts
in order to subdue someone they die you
have to knock them out you have to
bruise them make them bleed or whatever
but then with like the grappling Arts
you can
hold someone and like pull them down you
stun them out yeah without technically
without like breaking or making them
bleed or anything and then like that's
one of the reasons why we put taika and
Jiu Jitsu it's it's awesome that he's in
an activity but like right now he's
doing two activities one's Jiu Jitsu
wants basketball he's clearly way better
at basketball but I have more like that
he's way better he's honestly autistic
with basketball this feels just like
and they're all just going in and like
every every [__] practice I needed
you're like what the [__] give me Steph
Curry dude yeah he's really really good
at basketball
um and he likes it more but I just want
to have a base where I feel like okay
this guy could defend him because I know
bullies exist so if he at least has a
base where he can defend himself then
I'll go okay now you choose how you want
to spend more of your time but at least
as early as possible I want to get
something in where it's like this is
muscle memory so if [__] hits the fan he
has something to go to immediately you
know I just wanted to show a picture of
you the 13 year old girl yeah and it's
cool because
even in this article it says like what's
really really dope is that when she put
her when she put the bully in the arm
bar she could have broke that girl's arm
but she didn't and just based off of
what you're saying it's like you can
take somebody down so do them without
necessarily causing them that type of
harm
let her coach see that video and then
give her the next belt yeah I have no
idea but I'll be sick I like that you
can mess someone up without there being
Visual Evidence yeah I mean like what me
and my friends did tissues fourth grade
you know we're just like you know what
in fourth grade We're not gonna get
bullied and then um we're really scared
of getting bullied so we ended up doing
is we just got the tallest kids in all
of the grades and we started attacking
them and making fun of them and what we
realized was we were the bullies
it's a very good novel